the Biden Administration forced to come
clean on how their Progressive green
agenda is actually
benefiting China Biden's interior
secretary grilled on how the president's
policies blocked domestic production of
critical minerals creating a dependency
on the Communist Nation
of rare earth mining will stimulate to
it by deductive reasoning that would
mean that electronic Vehicles I'm sorry
electric vehicles and Renewables deepen
our Reliance on China correct
yes is it your policy the critical
minerals should be sourced from
countries that are stewards the
environment like the us and our allies
or sourced from Russia and China that
don't share our same values the
president is committed pretty much yes
and no it's your policy Madam our policy
is to
work to make sure we have the best
um I'll take that as a maybe
by twisting the inflation reduction act
to push climate policies saying this the
administration is attempting at every
turn to implement the bill it wanted not
the bill Congress actually passed but
transportation secretary Pete bootage
says Mansions claims cannot be true
because we all have electric cars
everything that we do in this
Administration conforms to the law as
written as passed by Congress and as
signed by the president of course we're
in constant dialogue with Partners in
Congress who have shaped this
legislation the way that the
administration is advancing this is
designed to ensure that we have Economic
Security that for example the electric
vehicle Revolution is a made in America
electric vehicle Revolution that
benefits American workers and creates
American jobs Jessica just I just want
to point this out while they're touting
you know we have EVS Biden's own energy
agency right now is predicting that EVS
will be only 10 percent of the global
car market by the year 2050. so this is
not happening fast they're not popular
we're not there yet and we have to admit
that but isn't it natural to ask the
question if we if we make this major
push to electric vehicles in this
country okay that means a major push for
batteries for those EVS and that means a
major push for lithium 70 to 75 percent
of all that lithium comes from China so
by pushing EVS aren't we increasing our
dependency on China
as the interior secretary said
yes
um there should have been a follow-up to
it I think at least on a policy
standpoint to say that although we do
have to work with China on a number of
issues and that's true of any
Administration no matter their politics
unless you want to fully isolate from
them a lot of companies are going to be
mad at you the Nikes of the world the
apples of the world what's the NBA going
to do Etc
um but there should be I think some
movement towards saying we're going to
give a little on this right allow more
of our own natural resources to be mined
here and understand that there is an
environmental cost to that to make sure
that we can lower our dependence on
China for that what's the difference if
the environmental cost is in China or
here well at America first right if
you're protecting Americans airspace
over I mean that's what this is right to
say okay well China is getting dirtier
and that's less of our problem than if
the United States is getting dirtier the
air that we're breathing here that's the
argument that every country is making
about their own policies no Global well
yes of course but go ahead with your
point I I think I made it I thought it
was
also Joe manchin had more control over
the inflation reduction act than any
single person these are crocodile tears
at this point he signed up on every
single word of it is completely
disingenuous for him to say that he was
duped breaking news because for once I
agree with half of what Pete butterjudge
said about Joe manchin Joe manchin
saying that he got duped about the
inflation reduction act when at the time
it was being passed it was clear and
evident in the text that it was the
biggest green new scam giveaway in the
history of the country and he signed
right onto it because he wanted to
appease Joe Biden and then he goes back
to West Virginia in his poll numbers
tanks and then all of a sudden now he's
against the inflation reduction act
which he voted for which he went to the
White House to tout after he voted for
it I'm sick of him and he might lose
re-election we'll see in terms of this
push for electric vehicles
um they keep selling this like it's
green clean energy Ryan zinke who's the
former interior secretary pointed out
today that in order to get this EV dream
they have to increase
mining by two thousand percent for the
next 20 years and Emissions was the only
standard that they're judging the
environment by us so they say an
electric car doesn't give off emissions
well it gives off a lot of emissions
when you're mining to build those
electric cars and it's a false bogus
standard which is going to result in
actually more detrimental policies for
the environment you're making too much
sense Katie this is a big cash transfer
from the taxpayers to Big Corporate
America and Joe Biden's just the
middleman doesn't have anything to do
with the environment it's all about
money we're doing this all in third
world countries we're doing it all in
China with slave labor with child labor
and the country and the world doesn't
get any greener
and that's the point the only green is
going through the pockets of corporate
America they're making green products
that we all of a sudden need to buy why
do we need to buy them because the
government's now mandating their
produced Mansion is an idiot he's
confessing that he got outmaneuvered by
Joe Biden how embarrassing I'm so sick
of him why is he so annoying
Joe manchin had the whole country like
this in his hand for about a year and a
half and then he folded and now he's
whining sorry Joe I don't feel sorry for
you you got lied to by Joe Biden get in
line the salsa maker Deb Holland she's
in charge of the Interior she's also a
basket Weaver and probably the dumbest
woman in the cabinet and that's saying a
lot has no idea the type of rare earth
minerals we're sitting here on this
country she doesn't even care she's an
Indian American that's why she was
putted interior she shatters so what and
now Corporate America tells her what to
do they're putting windmills owned by
foreign countries 15 miles off our
entire East Coast does that sound smart
to you well what happens if a German
company owns all of the real estate off
of New Jersey and then Germany is not
our friend anymore when's the last time
that happened oh maybe last century it's
the dumbest thing from a national
security standpoint I I've ever seen and
the fact that Joe Biden doesn't see that
tells me he's too old you know what it
was just last week Jen granholm the
energy secretary under this
Administration she doubled down on her
praise for China yeah that's crazy why
is this Administration not trying to
move away from dealings with China I
have a theory but first I have to defend
Ryan zinke I like the way he talks it
reminds me of a mysterious stranger from
the X-Files he just needs to have a
cigarette dangling out of his mouth a
green USA helps red China for obvious
reasons because it slams our economic
growth while bolstering theirs it's
basically what you would call climate
Equity right it's like we Tamp down our
economy because we're bad boys while
lifting there so we we are we all meet
at the same crummy horrible level but
it's so interesting why does the
American left and China always seem to
be on the same side whether it's the
stars of the NBA or the uh the heartless
Sunny hoston who's who defended the
imprisonment of uyghurs on The View I
doubt Their audience knew what the
uyghurs were uh but I thought they were
in Afghanistan yeah but why I mean but
why this alignment it's because they
both kind of share the same goal which
is to strip away the moral authority of
of America around the world the woke's
goal is to punish is to punish America
permanently that helps China this is why
China helps fund and support specific
companies that are woke that have ESG in
Dei or d-i-e because they create the
same desired outcomes which is a weak
Nation America that is at war with
itself that is why wokism is in China
loves wokism more than the wokesters
even realize
drop them
at the Michael I know very very good
very good very good all around all
around very good
point I think it really is
that was it for me hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else